and you're alive
german thank you thank you good
afternoon and welcome
to this performance governance and audit
committee
on monday the 25th of march 2021
sorry on thursdays 25th of march 2021
my name is councillor jeanette stilts
and i am the chairman of this committee
this committee meeting is held under new
regulations which come into effect on
the 4th of april in response to the
kovic 19 situation
and there are just a few housekeeping
issues to run
through first of all
please could you ask everyone present in
the meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted when not
addressing the committee this will
reduce background noise
and avoid any inter unintentional
disturbances this meeting is being held
hosted remotely streamed live and
recorded
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the
hands up function of the meeting to
indicate you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time members you are
reminded that apart from
indicating points of order or that you
have to leave the meeting the chat
function should not be used
for questions or any other purpose
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers
please ensure you reference a page or
paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible when invited to
speak
please ensure that you turn your
microphone and video on
now if i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting to introduce themselves
starting with mr dobson
good afternoon members paul dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance
good afternoon mrs miss donnelly
good afternoon emma donnelly video
internal audit manager
good afternoon miss hughes
good afternoon sheryl hughes programs
performance and governance manager
good afternoon mr leslie
good afternoon chris leslie director of
resources
good afternoon miss sweetly good
afternoon
hannah wheatley i'm the specialist
services manager good afternoon mr
wisdom
uh good afternoon um craig wisdom from
deloitte external order
good afternoon luna
good afternoon members brianna casey
clark to this afternoon's committee
thank you thank you bernard any other
officers present
i think we're supposed to have azaria
i thought i saw her logging in german
but i do know that mr wisdom is
presenting their report so maybe she has
left the meeting okay thank you burner
can i ask if there's any other
counselors that are in attendance before
we go to the roll call of
committee members
good afternoon everybody uh council
morris is here
lurking and um i've dressed down so that
councillor jarvis can look extra dashing
today
thank you thank you councillor morris
berna can you now carry out the roll
call of the committee members please to
confirm his in attendance
thank you chairman members i will call
your names in alphabetical order can you
please indicate you're in attendance
starting with counselor channel
good afternoon everyone yes i'm here
present thank you
counselor head
good afternoon everyone i'm present
thank you councillor hull
good afternoon yes i'm president jarvis
afternoon berna chairman members thank
you
cancer keys
cancer keys counselor none
yes hello berna good afternoon everyone
i'm present
thank you cancer counselor shaughnessy
good afternoon everyone uh president
berna thank you
council stamp good afternoon members
offices i'm present
thank you councillor stilts good
afternoon i am present
thank you thank you chairman thank you
um apologies for absence
can i have any apologies for absence
burner please
yes chairman we've received apologies
from counselor helm
thank you item three on your agenda is
the minutes
of the meeting held on the 25th of
february 2021
found on pages five to ten
um sorry they're not
they're fat yeah found on pages five to
ten um
can we say that these are true and an
accurate record
counselor heard
um thank you jim can you hear me okay
yes
uh yes uh page uh page eight
please um halfway
down uh the last bullet point
uh speaks it says conversation 80
businesses i presume that's meant to be
conversations with
80 businesses
yes yes cancer had yes thank you
thank you so we have page
five page six
page seven page eight
page nine and page ten is blank
iso move if you wish to second those
minutes please unmute your microphone
and state your name
second is joshua want to see thank you
councillor seancey
um can we take these by ascent
councillors agreed
thank you subject subject to my um
comments tim yes of course amendment yes
thank you
all right item for declarations of
interest to disclose the existence of
any nature of any disclosable community
interest
other pecuniary interest on
non-pecuniary interest relating to items
or
business on the agenda having regards to
paragraph 6 to 8
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are required that they are also
required to disclose any
such interests as soon as they become
aware should the need arise throughout
the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the hands up function now to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
counselor channel thank you chairman
non-pecuny interest is a member of essex
county council
um and any matter that pertains to that
on the reports and certainly is
mentioned
um about the flooding issue that essex
was referred to in that chairman and
other areas so
um i'm declaring the non-pecuniary in
relation to that um
in regard to that relationship thank you
thank you councillor channel are there
any other
declarations of interest burner
no chairman thank you
item five public participation
is there any members of public that have
indicated they wish to
speak under the
uh public participation burner no
chairman thank you thank you
item six on the agenda is the external
audit fees
i call a cop on mr leslie director of
resources
to give us an update
thank you chairman a briefing was
circulated to all committee members on
the 19th of march
which provided an update on the audit
phase
uh this followed a meeting with the
chairman vice chairman
and i with the psaa on the 16th of march
i'll now provide a summary of some of
the key points from that briefing
so following discussions with the
external auditors
the fee proposal which was nearly 100
000 pounds to begin with has been
reduced
to 88 and a half thousand
however 6 000 of that reduction uh
relates to the delay in the
implementation of a new accounting
standard
and that charge will be required again
the following year
when that accounting standard comes into
force
there was also um the allocation of 15
million
pound grant from central government in
respect
of the increased in audit fees just to
report back
that we have had no further update on
the allocations
yet um but we did have a very crude
estimate based on population and
estimated
it could be around 12 000 pounds
to grant to offset some of that cost but
that's a very crude
estimation just to provide some feedback
from the meeting with the psaa
they did recognize the significant
changes to the audit market that has
taken place
and that the original scale fees would
need to increase
they will be conducting independent
research to ascertain what
resembles a reasonable fee variation
in their view the psa
have not yet looked at the 2021
audit fees we did put across our
concerns
uh of course around those uh those fee
levels but uh
to date they are not considering those
uh
in terms of the process for approving
the fees uh once the audit is completed
likely towards the end of this canada
year the fee proposals will be submitted
by the external orders to the psaa
when they will have a look and review
that
part of that process will include them
asking questions of the external
auditors around the fee variations
asking for further evidence and
explanations where required
and if felt necessary they will indeed
look at audit files as well
and and finally they will of course
speak to the council
again to uh hear our views before they
make the final decision thank you jim
thank you mr leslie does anybody have
any questions on that
no i will move on then thank you very
much mr leslie
item seven on the agenda is the internal
audit report
a follow-up recommendations on payroll
and these are found on pages 11 to 36. i
call on miss donnelly to present three
reports
thank you miss donnelly yes good
afternoon
members so if we start with page 13 and
the progress report
this is to summarize how we've
progressed against the audit plan for
this year
and since the last committee we've
finalized one audit report which is the
payroll report which i'll talk through
in a minute
and we have one audit underway which is
knowledge management
and we have two audits in the planning
stage which are housing needs and
affordable housing
and management of property and we've
begun planning for next year obviously
we brought the annual plan to the last
committee for approval it's now been
approved and we've begun
and the planning stage for that so we
can report back on that in
the next meeting and we're also on track
to deliver our
annual report and head of internal audit
and opinion which will be bringing to
the next committee as well
any questions on the progress report
nope and i'll move on to the follow-up
report which
starts on page 18 and there's one
recommendation which has been
implemented relating to flood risk
management
and that was just around bolstering the
the knowledge within
the council on flood and risk which has
been implemented
and there's one overdue recommendation
for building control which we didn't
receive
and update on at the time of follow-up
but um
i believe officers might have an update
to provide at this stage
and then there are a number of other
recommendations which you'll note on the
table
and for flooding safeguarding and
information management which are not yet
you
so when they fold you you'll bring an
update on those to the appropriate
committee
any questions or is there an update on
the building control recommendation
i've got two hands up so
[Music]
chairman ms sweetly is going to provide
an update for us on the building control
i believe
oh thank you miss sweetly yes thank you
chairman
um yes in terms of the building control
audit action um the reason it's not
achieved the deadline that we last
stated is due to capacity issues
the building control team only consists
of two individuals
and they've been very much hit by the
kobe pandey in terms of the additional
workload
we are just in the process of securing a
third person to join the team
we interviewed this week and we hope to
appoint that they can start from the
beginning of may
so we are going to be having another
deadline for the end of september
so that our senior specialists can
document those procedures and we can
achieve that deadline
thank you thank you councillor
heard um i believe you've got your hand
up
uh yes thank you chairman um
i think my question has partly partly
been
answered uh just looking at page 22
which is the recommendations overdue
um it has crossed out december 20
and march 2021 in there so i presume
that will be that will change now to
september but also in the body of the
text
it says that the deadline for this audit
action will need to be extended to 31
12 20 which i presume will be 21
if it if it isn't i wondered why this
was
a high high priority
uh it's been partially explained
um by ms wheatley about
the update delay um
i would always like a little bit more
detail rather than
it's been delayed by covid i'd like to
know what the reason
uh for the delay was and that has been
that has been
partially answered so
my question is have we got the dates
right now
and can we just confirm which dates are
true
please miss wheatley
yes thank you councillor heard um
yes it really comes down to the fact
that there's just the senior specialist
who would be able to complete that
action
um because of the fact that there were
no site inspections done during the
first lockdown
all of that work has backed up so
they've had a year's amount of work to
complete in a nine-month period
because there's two of them they also
have to cover for leave
one of them did actually have covid in
march last year as well
which also impacted as i say we've
brought additional resources into the
team now
who hopefully be starting in in may um
so therefore we do expect that that will
free up some capacity for our senior
specialist to be able to document those
procedures
um so therefore i've had a conversation
with him he has made a start on them
um but just not got through as many of
them as he'd like to
but he does assure me that the end of
september this year is a realistic
deadline to have those now achieved by
thank you thank you thank you chairman
thank you mr
councillor hood um are there any other
questions
before we move on no okay
um i will move on then to the payroll
report which is in page
25. so as you can see this was a very
positive report
and with substantial assurance provided
we
reviewed starters levers over time
members expenses and alliances for the
period
april to december 2020
and we find two too low findings and
regarding
just having that documentation around
payroll can control reconciliations
just having the evidence that those have
been signed off and prepared
and by two separate individuals and also
and one law finding around and
just having like a new starter contract
being signed and on file
and but we didn't identify any
significant weaknesses
um around the the scope which i'll say
was for that design period of time able
to december 2020.
thank you any questions counselor nan
yes thank you chairman um can i take you
please to page
28 mr donnelly
are you okay
yes thank you at the bottom of the page
it says
two levers were paid the annual increase
effective from april 2020 but this was
not approved by the council until
september 2020
after their leaving date yes
so just help me with this is this the
national
is this the national pay award
yes so this was two people
who were eligible for that pay increase
and they left after the eligibility date
which was for the first of the april say
um i don't know the date to hand but say
for example they left
in july and those two people then were
back paid the april to july before they
left the increase that they were owed
so a national pay award doesn't require
council approval does it
i'm not i'm not sure in the details if
it was um
just a pay increase or i need to put
maybe chris i'll think about that
mr leslie would you like to come in and
answer that
yes thank you so yeah it's the national
pay award uh the council is signed up to
the njc
pay award so we go with that um there
obviously was
a pay award of um 2.75
last year um those staff uh received
their backdated pay but they had left
the council at the time
um but they were entitled to that pay so
it's just a case of the pay up lift
um had come into effect and it was
announced obviously after
the first of april so it was announced
after they had left
um so by the time they left they were
entitled to that pay
uh and it was paid so it's not really an
issue it was just that they were
they were entitled to that pay they just
happened to have received it after they
left the council
so hopefully that's it can i come back
chair on that please subscribe later
thank you
um so i agree partly that it isn't an
issue
uh in that uh people who are
under njc terms and conditions are
entitled automatically
to the pay award unless there's a
performance concern
and they've been given do you notice
that it should be withheld
so it's not really an order issue is it
that they
that the council needed to approve the
pay award
because the council doesn't need to
approve the pay award
the issue here is that when somebody's
left
if if they've left and they're not on
payroll
they need to make a claim for their back
pay
and it's not paid automatically so i
find that
um that entry on page 28 very
confusing mr leslie
yes yeah i think um you're right
councillor none it's probably the word
was not approved by the council
uh until september 2020. i could assume
that approved by the council means
perhaps
uh at an officer level in terms of the
council as a whole
approved the pay but i think i take your
point
uh it's looking like it wasn't properly
approved but um but indeed it was
properly approved and everything was in
order and i think uh miss donnelly
probably confirmed that there are no
issues
from their side and that everything was
in order around that
take your point okay thank thank you uh
through you chair thank you mr leslie
thank you miss donnelly i'll leave it
there
thank you councillor nan miss donnelly
have you and no that was that was
everything
and thanks chris um on that one um no
that was
everything from my side unless there's
any further questions okay
councillor stamp you've got your hands
up yeah thank you chairman just to
to um back up what counselor nuns said
is that going to be amended or is going
to be a little note put on the reports i
think it's a point well made because it
does read as though the council made the
decision not
the officers and i think that's
important because minutes have to be an
accurate true reflection
and i would ask that that is minuted or
amended somehow
thank you chair thank you can we do that
and chris thank you so recommendations
um that the committee considers uh
comments and approves the
one internal audit process reports
march 21 appendix one
two the follow-up of recommendations
report march
2021 appendix two and three
the payroll audit of february 2021
appendix 3 with that um
no for the payroll hold it counselor nun
you had your hand up
sorry you beat me to it chair i was just
going to say subject to that amendment
thank you
thank you so can i have a
seconder for that
for those motions please
well counseling on seconded thank you
councillor nan
our member's quite happy to take that
as um just
agreed thank you thank you bye
sen chairman agreed thank you bye saying
that's i was looking for the word
um item number
so i'm lost now uh-huh eight i think jim
i've had a problem with my printer this
morning so i'm
i'm sort of working off of notes at the
moment
item 8 annual audit summary letter
on the 21st on on the 2019
20 external audit found on pages 37 to
50.
i call on mr wilsdon to present
the ripple
thank you uh thank you chair uh and good
afternoon to everyone again um
this is a very brief report from me um
the report you have from us is as you
said our annual audit letter
um it's a document that essentially
summarizes all the audit reporting that
i've done to this committee
um yeah previously into a single sort of
summary document that
is then published on the councils and
psa website so
it's effectively like an executive
summary um to try and make the
to try and make the findings of my order
more accessible for
members of the public so because there's
it's just a summary and there's nothing
new in there um there's nothing new in
terms of conclusions or findings or
observations
uh chair i will take the document as as
read and
i'm happy to take any questions thank
you do i have any questions
for mr on the letter
no do i have any officers that would
like to comment
no so recommendation is to consider
and review the content of the letter
do i have a seconder for that chairman
obvious happy the second chairman thank
you
councillor chana
you muted yourself counselor channel
yes i was just about to having a bit of
trouble here
and that's answered it um i take it we
can consider
there was an appendices um with the
letter
yeah we can ask a question as my papers
have totally now disappeared off my
screen
and it was appendix appendix one yeah
the appendix one is with the letter
that's right
um letter to remember an appendix i was
quite concerned
about the um valuations issue
and now something having to be raised um
as being significant i wonder
if you could just clarify that all a bit
more please because there seemed to be
something with valuations
quite significant and because of it um
we needed to heighten um the issue to
being significant i just would like some
more
information on that valuations of money
on page 47.
yeah and um well it's actually there's a
few comments actually there's miss well
it mentions the misstatements as well
but here we are the valuation of
property assets 44
all right and it says we identified a
compensation error
it goes it really starts on there
there's a whole sort of tranche of it
all the way down
um and it does mention about the
requirement as
something is significant okay
mr wilston can you answer it
yes it's two and it talks about there's
um we've had to
elevate it to a significant risk because
this was the second year in a row
we've identified the material errors
uh i'm happy to respond to that um if i
may
and um council channel i mean i um
i i suspect um you you possibly went in
the meeting when we presented the final
audit letter because
um both myself and um officer leslie
went through
through the detail which i'll briefly
seminars summarize now for your benefit
um but at the last committee so
the committee has had has had sight of
that but in
a nutshell what it is is um you are
required to get
you are required to hold um certain
assets on your balance sheet
at um fair value and that means that
they need to be
valued by an independent valuer and the
council
employs a valuer to do that as part of
our audit
we come in and check that we use our own
real estate
um specialists to to sense check that
and uh we we found we have found uh
errors we found an error
in the 2019 orders as well as the 2020
world and
because we had found errors in the
valuation um two years in a row
that from an order perspective heightens
the risk
of error associated with that particular
balance
so when that kind when that happens we
elevate it to what we call a significant
risk so that's that's an ordered
term that we use when i elevate
something to an order a significant
order risk it means i
basically do more work on it so off the
back of
of those areas what we did do then is we
extended the work that we did
we worked with the council and the
valuer to um
to to understand what the cause of the
issues were
and we also asked them to actually um to
essentially double check some of the
historic
valuations that have been done which
they did as well
um so so but once we had completed all
of our work we were comfortable that
there were there were no further
material errors
and we were able to sign well i was able
to sign off on the uh on the audits
opinion
um i'll summarize briefly the council's
position and officer is
welcome to contradict if i miss
something out or say something wrong but
um in response to to the issues
um the council is also officers have
also have also
actively engaged with the valuer to find
out
why those issues happened there have
been discussions about them
um i think there have been changes
certainly um in the way
the valuer is going to do it in their
approach so there has been
there has been further conversations
between the council and the valuer to
make sure that
essentially this doesn't happen this
doesn't happen again
but as i say officer leslie i'm sure is
will add further
narrative if needed thanks thank you
um mr leslie you've got your hand up and
i know you're
desperate to come in and say something
on this thank you
mr wisdom's obviously covered uh a lot
of that but i just want to add that
um you know what we did was obviously
have those early discussions with our
auditors and see how we can improve the
process for
uh for next year looking at the
resourcing um that they have
as well so we started the conversations
very early we made sure we got the
information
um that we needed early from them so
we've actually we've received valuations
uh draft valuations a couple of months
ago uh which is very uh very timely
and we've been able to have a look at
that this year actually give good
challenge
around that now obviously we're not
qualified valuers but we can
have a sense check we can look at it and
we can check the work they've done
and we've gone back to them with
questions uh and being able to have a
robust process
around there for checking with the
valuers uh this year so
that's the sort of steps that we've
taken have the discussions early
meetings
and more robust checks of the
information that comes back
chairman might come back yes i will
allow you to come back to councillor
channel
thank you i'm not quite clear what was
the cause
um has been mentioned obviously checking
what the causes was
it seems that the dvs's quality control
procedures didn't pick up certain things
but it also clears that there's been a
lack of a review of property valuation
and valuation inputs
so i'm not quite clear on on the calls
which has led to this
that miscellaneously and how this has
been corrected i'm not quite clear of
what
actions have been put in place to remove
or mitigate this
occurring okay thank you councillor mr
leslie
yeah thank you so yeah the um errors
occurred
um the initial two errors in the two
years occurred
from a um i would say human error
in terms of the valuations that we
received
from that in both years obviously since
then we've had conversations uh
around actually the resourcing that
takes place
within there and do we need to look at
that so that's been put in place
we also have conversations with them
around the quality checking procedures
as well that takes place so they look to
improve that
themselves internally around resources
are provided and how they check
stuff before it gets sent to us and then
in addition to that we've looked at our
own
internal uh controls and looked at
making sure we get that information
early
engaging with them and actually
reviewing in a more robust way
what they submit to us and go back with
challenge which we which we have done
so thank you
um if you don't mind it counselor
channel was that
it because then i can move on to someone
else well i suppose one final question
we're confident then
um going forward um this is rectified i
guess
as much as it can be yeah i
think we've done everything possible and
i would point out that
um technically the valuations and with
the discussion with the um
external authors as well that actually
so the technical aspects of the
valuations
have been uh have been good um it's only
been a case of some of this
human errors that have come in so i've
looked at addressing that so i think we
have
confidence in the uh technical abilities
um
there but uh we feel we've done
everything possible to address this
issue
um going forward as i said you know
they've looked at their processes
they've looked at resourcing we're
looking at
challenging we've got things in early so
i think
we've done everything that i can see
possible um more reasonable at the very
least
thank you thank you very much thank you
chairman thank you
thank you i've got councillor heard's
hand up and then i had councillor stan
and councillor jarvis
um thank you chairman i'm just uh
looking at
page 48 which is the analysis of
audit fees um and i note that there is
an additional fee
due to change of scope due to covid and
asset valuation errors well we've spoken
about the asset valuation errors
uh i'm afraid it's it's the same old
chestnut with me
due to covid uh what difference has
covid made
and what change of scope has almost
given
rise to 50 on the charges of the fees
please thank you uh mr wilston
uh yes uh thank you so um
well there's two things first of all we
on on the fees we have provided a
detailed analysis
um to office leslie and um indeed had
it's been part of the discussions and
challenge
that council jarvis um
has has put to us as well so
specifically to covert and apologies
for for bundling it under a single
umbrella but it is
there are multiple elements to it so as
part of
as part of our our audit what our audit
is is for example a risk-based
uh audit and what that means is that you
know
we assess we do an initial assessment of
whether with uh individual balances
um what the inherent risk of error on
on individual balances now when covert
came along
that changed the inherent risk
associated with the number of balances
it made that risk higher
so for example covered meant that
people had to work remotely they had to
work from home
not just at the council but with your
suppliers and and
and others so the reason i come along
and think that the risk is heightened
now is because you know my when i look
at it i think that there is a there is
an increased inherent risk
that for example somebody working from
home might not follow the same
procedures as they would have
within the office i also think that
there may be delays
in you receiving information from your
suppliers because they are falling
behind because of inefficiencies with
remote working etcetera
so i'm just giving this as an example of
of one example but there are there are a
number so
as a result of that increased inherent
risk it meant that i had to
do additional procedures within my audit
um
to to to cover off that risk or to
satisfy myself that that
increase in inherent risk had not
resulted in an error
within the accounts so um i've given you
one example and we and again as i say
i'm happy to
to to provide further we we've done
we've had the discussions and the
analysis with officers
but there are a range of different areas
that that did that
so that is covert and so there's
multiple areas but
covert is the wrong banner it's it's
it's
extra auditing as a result of the impact
that covet had on a variety of different
areas
chancellor heard i will let you come
back
yes thank you chairman it is directly on
that can can we just be assured
uh that those additional fees uh were
authorized
by uh by the finance
uh by mr leslie and his staff as opposed
to
something that's just being looked at
please
thank you mr leslie yeah
thank you so yeah so ultimately i
suppose this goes back to the point that
the psaa
will have the final say uh on the fees
and they're looking at that
um at the moment uh in terms of the fees
we we've
discussed that with the external
auditors and feel that they are
uh reasonable uh in terms of that but of
course it's down to the psaa to make the
final judgment and they will look at
that
as well and assess what they deem
reasonable okay thank you
thank you uh councillor stamp you had
your hand up
i'm going to give a quick question based
on what counselor herz just said i'm
going to give way to cancer jarvis
because he was before me but i think uh
correct me if i'm wrong counselor heard
i think he was actually saying the way
my mind worked there it wasn't like a
blank check was
was the auditor uh craig wisdom actually
going to you mr leslie before he was
carrying out these additional work
was a risk assessment a financial risk
assessment to this council to say that
the fees were going to be higher because
it should all be pre-approved before
somebody just coming in and saying well
i'm going to have to do this so
was there a dialogue and were you happy
as a director
that they no disrespects i know you're
sitting in in the zoo meeting mr wisdom
but are you happy that we have had value
for money mr leslie
thank you mr leslie yeah thank you
yes um the the fees also went to a
committee
as well back in um at least in september
um time as well with the 2021 fees as
well so the committee have had sight of
those
and they've remained unchanged from the
one that the committee saw
um i think i've as i said before um the
external
to work very well with the external was
very pleased um with how they've done
we've worked together to get the account
signed off so from from my
uh perspective we've had good value for
money from our auditors
obviously it's a shame that we have to
pay more and i'll accept that but at the
same time i understand that they do need
to do more work
uh around that side of it and they have
obviously informed us
with their letters et cetera and so i'm
satisfied
from my point of view thank you
councillor jarvis you've been patiently
there with your hand up
yeah thank you very much chairman i've
just uh initially i think my hands up
with regards to councillor chandler's
point but uh if i may come back on
council channels and councillors
i mean the the issue of asset valuation
was a concern
we did discuss it in detail in november
so we have had the conversation on it
before as craig wisdom quite rightly
said
his report today is a summary of not new
points but points which have been raised
and debated before but
obviously worth going through anything
which uh if somebody hasn't sort of
picked up on it but
we have we have discussed that before
the 9 000 pound associated with the
asset valuation
this was the second year uh the the
there was a failing mainly a failing
with an external body
um and uh but of course that should have
been picked up on
uh and shouldn't have occurred and we've
heard that chris leslie
quite rightly has uh says he's addressed
that issue
both with internal procedure and also
what the external
body do in terms of their performance uh
you'll see that that nine thousand pound
which is in um uh the the an expense for
the the last audit
i mean that hasn't actually yet been
agreed i have to say both that
and the cave in seven thousand seven
hundred on the schedule that chris
legend
distributed those two numbers are
essentially up for the pssa
to determine uh whether they are
reasonable or not
it has to be said though that as a
council we have said that
based on uh our examination of what
occurred and based on
uh records etc that we're happy to
support those fees
for uh the last audit year um
so i think you know so as i say so some
of that discussion has taken place
before we have seen those figures before
uh and i think uh chris lester and craig
based on reiterated
think things have been done internally
so that uh to the best of
our knowledge that that won't occur
again so uh
i think that's good as far as the other
point is concerned on kobe
um there's the sort of seven thousand
seven hundred yeah there is seven
thousand seven hundred
in last year again that is an item which
is further appears to say to determine
and they've got it in front of them at
the moment to do that
and as far as that figure being in a
game for next year and that's
very much um just a uh in there as a
sort of budget number
none of the numbers other than the scale
fee uh essentially are uh pre-approved
by
by council yeah they they go in as uh
where we where we think the estimate
might be or where craig wisdom thinks
the estimate might be
we can ship that down which is what
we've done and those numbers uh which
currently
essentially add up to uh 88 000
less less obviously the uh currently 88
000.
that's what sort of will ultimately go
to pssa if um
you know if that's what eventually comes
in on the bill that's seven thousand
seven hundred for kovid is craig
wisdom's estimate of what the figure
might be
so ultimately what will happen is
they'll do the audit and um that figure
maybe that amount it might be us
a much smaller amount we hope but in any
case whatever it is
all of those numbers bar the scale fee
get reviewed by psaa
and we also get the opportunity to say
whether we're happy to support the
numbers that have gone in or not
we currently are supporting the numbers
for last year
currently we're saying that we're not
supporting the substantial increases
for this year so it would be wrong for
councillors to think that we just sort
of rolled over and agreed to reduce
budget
we've got to reduce budget but we're
specifically at the moment
saying to psaa actually we don't we
don't we don't agree with those numbers
of course we don't know twice as much as
the scale thing quite a lot more than
last year
and it will be up to them then to have a
discussion and work out psa whether
whether that's whether that's reasonable
or not based on filing
inspection or not so i just wanted to
sort of give a little bit of detail
there
um to the process going on i think chris
leslie's got it very much under control
i think craig wisdom knows exactly where
he is on the matter
thank you chairman thank you councillor
jarvis uh councillor chandler you have
your hand
i have actually um uh chairman yes
i appreciate discussions may have been
taking place before but i'm sorry
chairman perhaps i might have not quite
caught on with the situation the gravity
of it though
i now consider i have on having it come
round if you like second time again
and i think as a member i am entitled to
ask those questions the point i might
feel i
need further questioning and answers to
find myself content
i rather like the hundred thousand
pounds where if you recall and it wasn't
just me alone
i think several members hadn't quite
appreciated the doubling of the audit
fees that was then sort of report and it
was sort of said
oh well this was in the letter and i
you know whatever the letter was i still
don't know that it was quite clear
under a thousand pounds was the perhaps
intended increase
and in fact then we had to a summary at
the last meeting of
mr leslie sort of doing a verbal quick
update at
the previous meeting so i do apologize
if i might appear slow to some people
coming in on these matters but i will
always ask questions if i do find myself
having to go over something and not
thoroughly understanding it
madam chairman and i think that's
perfectly accepted within the confines
of this committee so i just wanted to
make those points
i think members need to speak up if they
feel there's something that's
now come to their registration much more
acutely
and sort of get answers thank you very
much
thank you miss uh councillor chana of
course we
you know we've tried to keep the members
updated with everything that's gone on
and as councillor leslie said
uh sorry mr leslie said and councillor
jarvis
we we have had more talks to try and
bring the number down because none of us
were happy with that hundred thousand
and as you're right we this is the place
where we should
discuss these things and we should ask
these questions
i suppose ma'am jen i was feeling a bit
like a naughty school girl
um people telling me we've had these
discussions before
you know as though my brain should have
taken it all on and been absolutely
clear
yes and you know i do feel that if my
brain wasn't clear which it obviously
wasn't that's why i felt i needed to ask
further questions thanks
thank you counselor jana as any other
questions
on this um
annual audit letter summary letter
now so if counselors are happy with
that can i have a secondar
for the recommendation which was to
consider and review the content of the
letter
give it a second that thank you
councillor jarvis
and do members wish to agree this by con
a saying agreed agreed
thank you we will move on to item
nine on your agenda which is the staff
survey headline results these are found
on page 51-56
and i call on miss hughes to present
the item
good afternoon members this report is
presented to the committee as an update
on the recent staff survey
which ran between september and november
2020
this is the second year that we've run
the survey internally which allows us
also to now benchmark year on year
you will see in section 3.2 of the
report that we received a good response
rate of 72 percent of staff
and overall the responses to the survey
show a positive increase in staff
satisfaction between
2019 and 2020 we included additional
questions this year
around the impact of covid on our staff
and preferences for future ways of
working
and these have also been fed into
associated work streams
section 3.3 shows areas where staff
satisfaction had increased
and also where it was at its lowest
in response to this the extended
leadership team met in january to review
the full results
and feedback and identify an action plan
to address some of the staff concerns
the action plan is attached to appendix
a to give members reassurance that staff
feedback is being addressed
through these high-level actions behind
this action plan there are detailed
action plans and areas of responsibility
that have been identified
so that we can implement it
operationally the communications team
and the internal one team champions have
also been turning the plan into a format
of
you said we did which will be launched
shortly to staff
members are invited to review and
comment on the information set out
through this update
and confirm assurance that the staff
feedback is being managed effectively
thank you thank you mrs
um ansel heard you have your hand up
yes thank you um thank you chairman uh i
just want to confirm that we've got uh
we've got the dates right because i've
got here um
uh that this was uh
areas of first of all i i'm glad to see
that there were
uh some good uh areas of satisfaction
and and i know that this was actually
prior to the administration up to the
1st of november 2020.
um but the low areas of satisfaction
which is of course what we're being
asked
to look at talk about insufficient
resources
low satisfaction on mdc's
future vision and low satisfaction on
career
development now there was a workshop run
i think it says january 2020 is that
meant to be january 2021
uh so i'll pause there because if it
if it's january 20 i've got another
point so could uh
could misuse confirm the date of the
workshop
misused uh sorry which uh which workshop
are you uh which point in the reports
are you referring to
uh 3.6 the management team held a
workshop in january 2020
oh sorry that should say 2021 you're
right that's just an error in the typing
so that's the that's the workshop that i
was referring to where the action plans
come from
right okay that's fine so because
obviously that would have been
pretty locked down and not really not
really relevant to what we
to what we were doing um so
if we're looking at these three areas of
low satisfaction
um the question is did ignite
get it wrong that's my question chairman
hughes do you want to come back chairman
i don't think that's a fair question to
ask i'm sorry and it's
especially under purder i'm sorry uh
councillor heard
i i don't normally jump in and stop
freedom of discussion and speeches and
everything but
i don't think it's fair to ask an
officer that question um
um it it's happened we have to
adhere and move forward to it sorry
council heard i hope you don't think i'm
being
a little bit unfair uh but i'm happy i'm
happy to read i'm happy to rephrase
i'm happy to free phrase the question uh
are we then uh are we happy that we are
able
to address these three areas
uh as a result of the workshop
so um the action plan attached um
as the appendices um for things like
increase in workload and pressure
and one of the actions is that we are
actually breaking down
um you know which areas uh staff
feedback because um
given the time some of that i know it's
your least favorite thing but some of
that will be related to covid pressures
as well where people were doing extra
processes
um on top of their normal day job and so
we're trying to work out and
attribute those staff pressures to um
covid or just their normal day-to-day
role
as well and so we're doing some work on
that and we do think that will help us
to identify
um where some things might be to do with
organizational look and then some things
might be to do with
just the pressure of kobit as well
okay thank you can i just can i just say
uh nothing to do with purder i just
wanted to make sure that we've got the
numbers right
uh that's all i'm after thank you miss
sweetly you wanted to come and say
something
before i move on to another counsellor
yes uh thank you chair
um i just wanted to also make the point
that we have actually brought some
additional resources in
um they weren't in situ at the time that
the survey was completed
but within service delivery we've
appointed i think off the top of my head
about another eight rolls across the
teams
so that has relieved some of the
pressure but of course at the time the
survey was completed
we hadn't appointed into those
additional vacancies
and so we are in a much better position
now but we will continue working on
those
points that were raised through the
survey thank you
okay thank you now you have your hand up
thank you um yeah i i you know i've
found over the years that staff surveys
are really important but it's equally
important that they're ready in context
and you know we are living through
unprecedented times
whether we like it or not covid does
have an impact on
staff motivation and morale and of
course new ways of working so i you know
i'm
not surprised that the results are
coming out
in some some respects in the way that
they are
but the the the action plan needs to be
read in context
uh by reading the full report because
the full report gives the
the bigger picture the bigger story and
what's really important coming out of
this is the action plan
um it's great to see that well-being is
up
and i think that's a credit to
management
uh the city i'm not talking about
members i'm talking about officers
this is a credit to the senior
management team that
they have taken care of their staff
during these
unprecedented times so it's good that
well-being's up
development and direction seem to be
down
but actually when you look at the report
unless i've misread the report
the highest negatives
that make sense our love the highest
negatives are love
the highest negatives are between 18 and
28
the highest positives are high
in that they're between 91 and 94
so you actually can almost work that out
to the numbers of staff
that have said the things they've said
now again without me
talking out of turn there are always
staff
who have particular views either in a
rosy way
or a non-rosy way and then you get
people in the middle that
sort of just have views so i just think
we need to take that
all of that into account and what i
would ask madam chairman is that
through through you whether the officers
feel that it would be useful
for this committee to monitor
implementation of the action plan
in terms of what's happened and the
impact that that action plan has had
thank you very much thank you councillor
nan i think that would be a good idea um
mr dobson i know you're on this call are
you happy
with councillor nan's suggestion that we
monitor this
yes we'd be happy to um bring back a
further report on
on progress with this as we've we've
shown there's a clear action plan in
place
much of the information will be through
the um balance scorecard in any case
some of the
the staffing information comes through
that and the final results
of the changes will be through the
only known really when we do the survey
next year to have the comparable results
but more than happy to to bring back a
report um
updating on the actions that we've
outlined
and the you said we did approach to
what what we've taken generally to be a
very positive
staff survey i think the responses
have generally been positive um
you're obviously going to get positives
and negatives within any survey
but the uh the responses showed a big
improvement
um from previous years i think and
we've been able to put in a clear plan
that
shows that we can address those issues
so a really positive
process i think and yes happy to report
back
thank you thank you mr dobson i had
counselor channel uh
councillor stamp and then councillor
chennai's hand up so if i go to
councillor stamp
next uh thank you chair um no i think
it's great reports
i was really really happy when obviously
the areas of concern was that
they some officers and some staff were
working harder
and felt they couldn't cope and i think
this uh the
directors and the senior leadership team
was well aware of that
as well we know when we've had meetings
and
all members have raised awareness and
concerns to make sure there's a
work-life balance
and i know one particular counselor i
won't mention any names because i don't
want to be
in trouble has always said that
they were concerned and should be
turning their phone off and this that
member is actually here sitting here
most probably grinning at the moment
and knows i'm referring to her so it's
really vitally important
that the directors do still keep on top
of
um the sometimes the overloading of
certain staff
but miss wheatley's really is completely
right
they have introduced and employed new
staff and i think there will be a better
work life
and home life balance but we also must
appreciate that
having to work from home has its
benefits as well as its
uh drawbacks but i was actually
heartened uh
to read this report and for the honesty
of the staff
because it's not always easy to turn
around and fill a form in or a survey
if you're feeling a little bit you know
over over stretched on pressure
and covid has but not just this
authority
everywhere put additional stress on
workers directors
and members and i just think it's very
well done and i welcome
mr councillor none to actually ask for
it
to to have a follow-up on that i think
it's vital we keep an eye on the staff
because the pandemic isn't over
and we still need to keep it at this
high level so i
no questions it's just a comment and
thank you very much and a good report
thanks thank you councillor chana
um thank you um well i'm not being
critical of the report and i agree
with much much sorry with what much has
been
said i can't even get my teeth in
straight these days and um counselor
nuns had the benefit of being able to
read the
detailed reports unfortunately i haven't
because i can't access it like you madam
chairman
so um the areas that did actually just
concern me or that's been
explained to a degree and it is actually
to do with the staff development and
training and i appreciate you have had
covid and obviously it's changed the way
we all work and everything and um
all online can i just inquire though um
it is important and i see objectives has
been referred to
that actually that every officer does
recognize how important their role is
in the authority regardless whether
they're top of the tree or at the bottom
of it
and equally important that they perhaps
do understand how their role is that
very important cog in the wheel that
turns
and you know one cog missing can affect
the whole movement of a wheel
and therefore regarding objectives um
can i be given some assurance
that we still do go through the process
of the personal development plans it
might be when the appraisals are done
and that would give an indication of
when the training is but do we make
staff
recognize the importance of them and re
and help them
i'm sure they do know anyway but maybe
to know how their objectives
um do actually fall into the big picture
without their objectives actually the
big strategic
outcomes wouldn't be possible so i
suppose my question is
have we been able to maintain to a
degree staff appraisals
personal development plans which would
actually um place a record on files for
each and every individual um
you know precious officer we've got to
ensure they perhaps do recognize they
will get training
um i just felt to say we're going to
have put together an old staff annual
training timetable
um i was thinking how does that apply to
the individuals because the individuals
are very very important
and every individual needs to feel
valued and also recognize how important
their particular role is within the
machine
if i wanted a better word or the wheel
turning so
i just would like sort of a bit of
background on that if i may thank you
madam chairman thank you i had miss
weeklies and mr dobson's hands go up at
exactly the same time so which one of
you would like to respond
first
mr dobson
um mrs wheatley can um provide some of
the
um background on the actions in in that
particular area
um i think we really value the
um performance management process
and we make sure you know in terms of
addressing
all of these issues we've just um
had approval from council for the
updated um corporate
plan and it's really important that we
have that
um not least in addressing some of the
issues that were within the
um survey around the the need for clear
vision and direction which i think
again was a a fair comment having been
through
it was two years since the publication
of the original plan and then we've been
through covid as well so things have
changed
um but i mentioned that because really
it's about that golden
thread that flows from the corporate
plan
through service plans through everyone's
smart objectives
and into the jobs they do so as as
counselor channel absolutely rightly
says
everybody is vital in delivering
everything that we do
um throughout the whole organization and
if
if there's a problem in one area then
then it has a can have a major issue
so we do go through that process um we
have set the smart
objectives um annually and we
made sure that those were were kept up
through the
um start of last year through the
pandemic um that does include
making sure there's reference to all of
the um
corporate plan the service plan and the
training needs um
that people have within those to make
sure that we um
summarize those understand them and the
track they will obviously
inform the training plan that's referred
to
within the actions so yes
we definitely have all of that in place
um
and looking this year to ensure as well
that we um
embed the the corporate values that are
in the new corporate plan
through that smart setting objectives as
well
thank you thank you miss sweetly
yes thank you so just just building on
what mr dodson said
um we we do have regular one-to-ones the
one-to-ones take place with
every officer every six to eight weeks
and in those one-to-ones we do use that
opportunity to discuss
their mental health to discuss those
development opportunities
and we are in the process of setting
objectives for the next financial year
um there have been challenges with
training remotely but we have been doing
training over the last 12 months via
teams
um but we would very much look forward
to doing that face-to-face when we're
able to
kind of go back to the office and use
the rooms to be able to do training and
team meetings because there are some
challenges that come with doing it
remotely
but that being said the feedback that
we've had from offices that have been
trained remotely
is still very positive and in reference
to the additional roles that we've
created
a number of internal staff have had the
opportunity to actually progress
and develop their careers so there's
also been the opportunity for career
progression and we do very much
recognize the strengths and the
abilities that our officers have
and look to enable them to develop and
progress within the authority in terms
of that career development
so that focus has very much been there
over the last 12 months
thank you thank you councillor chandler
you did have your hand
up was did you want to come back
down now is it going down your end
yeah you've just taken it down but i
wondered if you still wanted to come
back on it
thank you
so if everybody's happy with that we'll
move to the recommendations which is
that the committee review and comment on
the staff survey results and the
associated action
plan which you you've all done and that
members confirm
through this that they are sure that the
staff survey response is being managed
effectively
so if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn your mic
none seconded thank you councillor now
our members happy to agree
by ascent agreed
thank you item 10 any other item on the
business
of business on the agenda um the only
thing i will say
is that this is the very last meeting
before the statutory annual for
pgna and i would like to thank every
officer
and every committee member for all the
support and help that you've given me
throughout
this time as
chair so thank you for that so item on
the 11
on the agenda is the closure of meeting
um thank you for your contributions this
afternoon
i draw the meeting to a close at 1506
p.m meet me as members
leave the meeting you advised not to
enter into any further discussion on
this forum
and can you leave promptly thank you
very much
thank you chairman thank you thank you
thank you
thank you thank you bye